자 오늘은 오랜만에 모든 주가지수가 떨어지고 있습니다.
나스닥도 1% 넘게 떨어지고 있고
다우지수 0.76%, S&P500 0.7% 떨어지고 있고요.
뭐 왜 떨어졌냐? 쉽게 말하면 호르무즈 관련된, 이란 관련된 이슈가 악화가 됐고
또 하나는 소프트웨어 주식들이 현재 최악의 움직임을 보이고 있습니다.
이 두 가지가 합쳐지면서 시장을 끌어내리고 있습니다.
특히 브렌트유도 배럴당 103달러가 넘고 WTI도 95달러를 돌파했어요.
그래서 오늘도 유가는 더 올랐다.
왜? 호르무즈 해업과 관련된 긴장이 고조가 됐기 때문입니다.
호르무즈 관련된 이슈는 뭐가 있었느냐?
일단 트럼프가 호르무즈 해업에 기뢰를 설치하는 선박들을 있으면, 보이면 다 쏴라 이렇게 명령을 했습니다.
이란은 계속 미군이, 미군이 지금 이란 앞바다를 봉쇄하고 있잖아요.
이거 계속하면 협상...
협상 안 한다라고 선언을 한 상태고요.
그리고 이게 이따가 말씀드릴 또 결정적인 건데,
이스라엘 국방장관이 전쟁을 재개하려고 한다.
이런 또 얘기를 했어요.
그래서 이런 게 좀 이스라엘 국방장관의 멘트가 결정적이지 않았을까?
뭐 이런 생각이 드는데,
다만 이런 것도 있긴 한 것 같아요.
최근 정말 한 2주 정도 계속 주가가 연속으로 오르니까,
사실 오늘 하루 정도는 뭐 마이너스가 날만도 하지 않나?
뭐 이런 생각도 들기는 하는 거죠.
그리고 또 어떤 일도 있었냐면,
미국이 인도양까지 따라가서 이란의 석유를 실은 초대형 유조선을 직접 올라가서 막았습니다.
미국도 어떻게 보면 좀 절박한 모습,
어쨌든 이란의 돈줄을 끊겠다라고 하는 강한 의지 보이고 있고,
이란은 역시 이란대로 호르무즈 해업의 거의 봉쇄 상태를 유지하고 있습니다.
다만 제가 방금 또 말씀드렸다시피,
이스라엘의 국방부 장관인 카츠가 뭐라고 얘기를 했냐면,
우리는 미국의 승인을,
하멘의 왕조와 이란의 테러 정권 지도부 전체를 끝장내기 위해서 기다리고 있다.
그리고 우리는 이란을 암흑기로 되돌리고 그들의 에너지와 전력시설 폭파하고 전체 경제를 짓밟겠다라고 이렇게 얘기를 하고 있습니다.
자 그리고 이란은 같은 시간에 병원들을 비상사태에 돌입시켰고 소규모 안보 내각이 소집되고 있다라고 합니다.
자 미국과 이란이 계속 뭐 으르렁 하는 거는,
어쨌든 협상의 의지가 있으니까 요거까지는 괜찮지 않나 싶다가도 이제 또 다른 변수죠.
이스라엘이 이렇게 나서다 보니까 시장에서 간만에 좀 부정적으로 해석을 한 것 같아요.
그래서 요 이슈를 좀 부정적으로 시장이 보면서 시장이 좀 하락폭이 커지고 있다 이렇게 볼 수가 있겠고,
다만 이제 이스라엘이 진짜 액션을 할지 말로만 끝날지 요런 걸 또 알 수가 없으니까,
이 전쟁과 관련돼서 제가 드는 느낌은 진짜 뭔가 하려고 하면 오히려 엇박을 탈 수가 있기 때문에 정말 정말 조심을 어떤 행동을 할 때가 되기 때문에,
정말 정말 조심을 어떤 행동을 할 때가 되기 때문에,
조심을 해야 되는 것 같습니다.
그리고 오늘 사실 더 큰 소프트웨어 업계에서 정말 충격적인 뉴스가 있었는데,
바로 마이크로소프트의 구조조정을 하는 그런 뉴스가 있었습니다.
마이크로소프트가 미국에 있는 직원을 직원의 7% 대상으로 희망퇴직을 진행을 했는데요.
이게 마이크로소프트 역사상 가장 큰 규모의 자발적 퇴직 프로그램이라고 합니다.
그래서 약 8,700명을 감원을 할 거다라고 하고요.
나이 더하기 근속,
연수가 70이 넘는 사람은 이제 희망퇴직을 하는 그런 기준이 된다라고 하는데,
제 나이가 제 나이가 대충 제 나이 딱 봐도 한 뭐 한 서른 초반으로 보이죠.
저 나이 서른 초반 근속연수 뭐 한 5년 정도 일했으니까 합치면 서른다섯 저는 해당이 안 되겠네요.
해당이 안 되는 상황인 것 같은데 어쨌든 간에 그 마이크로소프트 같이 돈을 정말 잘 버는 회사조차 이렇게 희망퇴직을 한다라는 거 자체가,
매우 충격적인 뉴스였고,
그럼 마이크로소프트가 왜 희망퇴직을 하느냐?
결론만 얘기했을 때는 바로 AI 인프라 투자 때문입니다.
왜냐하면 마이크로소프트도 지금 데이터 센터나 AI 인프라에 어마어마한 돈을 투자를 하고 있거든요.
심지어 몇 시간 전에 호주 AI에 18조 원 투자하겠다라고 얘기를 했어.
마이크로소프트가 그러니까 마이크로소프트는 계속 AI 데이터 센터를 지어야 되니까,
이거를 아끼기 위해서 직원들을 내보내는 겁니다.
그리고 실제로 요즘에,
소프트웨어 회사들,
저도 지인들이 소프트웨어 회사를 다니고 있으니까 얘기를 듣는데,
요즘에 업무 생산성이 너무 좋아져서 주는 일들을 다 빨리빨리 해결하고 있는 상황이다라고 하더라고요.
그러니까 다시 말해서 기존 인력들이 이제 더 이상 필요하지 않는 거야.
인력을 훨씬 줄이고도 예전에 주어졌던 일들을 할 수가 있는 그런 상황이 됐습니다.
그러니까 마이크로소프트도 자연스럽게 이런 방향 속에서 희망퇴직 프로그램을 실시하는 거고요.
요즘에 이게 마이크로소프트만 이러고 있는 게 아니라,
오라클,
메타 다 똑같이 하고 있습니다.
그래서 AI에 돈을 쏟아 부으면서 인건비를 줄이는 걸 동시에 하고 있는데,
소프트웨어 관련된 회사들이 진짜 무차별적으로 박살이 나고 있습니다.
너 소프트웨어야?
그럼 일단 박살 나고 보는 거예요.
그냥 지금 그런 상황이고,
뭐 인프라건 어플리케이션이건 안 가리고 그냥 다 박살이 나고 있고,
여러분들이 많이 좋아하시는 팔란티어 6% 하락을 하고 있고,
어둡이 7% 서비스 나오고,
이따가 말씀드릴 건데 17% 하락하고 있고,
그냥 뭐 어마어마하게 다 하락을 하고 있어요.
자, 반면에!
어떤 상황입니까?
반도체는 반대예요.
엄청 잘 나가고 있어.
인텔 4% 올랐고,
텍사스 인스트루먼트 이거 실적이 좀 잘 나왔거든요.
19% 오르고 있고,
그래서 반도체 관련된 뭐 어제 좀 많이 올랐던 마이크론 이런 애들은 좀 쉬어가고 있지만,
대부분 반도체 주식들,
하드웨어 주식들은 좋다.
이렇게 정리를 할 수가 있겠고요.
자, 서비스나우는 굳이 말하자면 뭐 경영지원,
총무 이런 거를 소프트웨어로 해주는 회사다 라고 생각을 하시면 됩니다.
이것도 구독 소프트웨어 회사거든요.
사스라고 불리는.
예를 들면 이런 거죠.
직원이 노트북이 고장 났어요.
아니면 휴가를 승인해 주세요.
접근 권한 요청합니다 라고 하면은,
이런 것들을 뭔가 저장을 해야 되고,
이거를 세팅을 할 수 있게,
이거를 승인 요청도 하고,
승인도 해줄 수 있는 어떤 단일한 시스템이 필요하겠죠.
그런 시스템을 서비스나우에서 제공하고 있다 라고 생각을 하시면 됩니다.
자, 근데 그런 서비스나우가 오늘 실적을 발표했는데 18%가 떨어졌어요.
자, 왜 서비스나우가 18%가 떨어졌는지,
사실 이번 분기 실적은 괜찮았는데,
다음 분기 이익률 가이던스가 시장의 예상보다 낮게 나왔습니다.
무려 5%포인트나 낮게 나오면서,
시장이 야 생각보다 돈을 못 남기네 하면서 이제 후드려 팬 거고요.
자, 5%포인트 뭐 꽤 큰 수치이긴 한데,
야 이걸 이렇게까지 팰 건가 싶은 생각도 좀 들기는 들어요.
그래서 오늘 지금 어떤 상태냐면,
소프트웨어와 반도체 주식을 비교를 하면,
지금 소프트웨어 주식이 반도체 주식 대비해서 훨씬 더 나쁘게 움직이는,
그런 소프트웨어 주식 최악의 날이다라고 할 수가 있겠습니다.
상대적인 주가의 움직임이 역대 최악이에요.
뭐 어떻게 보면 진짜 이게 정말 찐 소프트웨어의 움직임이라고 볼 수도 있는 거니까,
소프트웨어 주식이 오늘 투자 심리가 그 정도로 안 좋다라고 볼 수가 있겠고요.
자, 소프트웨어 주식 관련돼서는 AI가 소프트웨어 주식을 죽이고 있다.
이런 얘기가 많잖아요.
이런 얘기를 할 때마다 뭐 언제나 정답은 없겠지만,
과거에서 조금은 힌트를 찾을 수가 있을 것 같아요.
그래서 과거에는 어떤 스토리가 시장을 정복하고 있었냐면,
신문회사가, 인터넷 회사들이 신문회사들을 죽일 것이다.
요런 그런 시각이 팽배했었는데요.
그래서 전체적으로 한번 보면은,
2002년부터 2011년까지 신문회사들의 주가입니다.
자, 그냥 사정없이 떨어졌어요.
근데 더 무서운 건 뭐냐면,
2003년부터 2007년은 그래도 미국 시장이 꽤 좋았거든요.
미국 주식시장이 계속 우상향하는 와중에도,
신문회사들은 우하향했다라는 정말 무서운 결과가 있고,
더 무서운 건 뭐냐면,
주가는 그냥 일단 계속 떨어졌는데,
사실 실적은 2002년부터 한 2006년, 2007년까지는 잘 버텼습니다.
이때까지는 신문회사들의 실적이 나쁘지가 않았거든요.
근데 주가는 먼저 떨어졌다는 거예요.
이게 다시 말하면,
주식적으로 표현하면 멀티플부터 깎인 거죠.
실적이 계속 잘 나와도 시장이 불안하니까,
좋은 멀티플을 주지 않으면서 주식이 계속 하락을 했다.
물론 결과적으로 그들의 생각이, 투자자들의 생각이 맞았죠.
왜? 2007년 이후에는 신문회사들의 실적이 매우 안 좋아졌기 때문이죠.
그래서 제가 약간 이 시장을 보면서 느끼는 건,
시장은 지금 무차별적으로 팔아 제끼는 상황입니다.
그런데 저는 분명히, 제가 이거 지난번에도 말씀드렸는데,
저는 분명히 최종 승자가 있을 거예요.
그러니까 소프트웨어 회사들 중에서 다 죽지는 않을 거야.
일부는 살아남을 건데,
이거를 지금 시장에서 당장 판단하기가 너무 어려운 상황입니다.
그러다 보니까 투자자들 입장에서 일단 매도하는 거죠.
일단 매도하고 보는 거야.
저는 심지어 실적이 잘 나온다고 해도,
방금 제가 보여드린 표를 보셔서 아시겠지만,
시장은 계속 의심을 할 거고,
멀티플을 계속 축소시킬 거라고 생각을 합니다.
그래서 시장이 계속 팔아 제낄 가능성이 높다라고 생각을 하기 때문에,
소프트웨어 주식을 투자할 때는 조금 더 큰 주의가 필요하다고 생각을 해요.
다만, 반도체 지금 지수도 그렇고,
반도체의 움직임이 지금 16일 연속 이익인 상황이거든요.
너무 단기적으로 극단적인 과매수 상태여가지고,
단기적으로는 반도체 주식이 조금 안 좋을 수도 있겠다.
하드웨어 주식들 안 좋을 수도 있겠다.
이런 생각이,
들기는 들어요.
반대로 또 소프트웨어한테 좋을 수도 있겠는데,
너무 극단적으로 지금 단기적으로 가니까,
그럼에도 불구하고,
중장기적으로 소프트웨어 주식 투자에는 정말 주의가 필요하다는 생각을 저는 가지고 있습니다.
그 외에도 AI와 관련된 것들,
짧게만 조금 더 짚어보면,
이번에 구글이 블로그에서 발표한 바에 따르면,
구글이 새롭게 작성하는 코드의 75%는 AI가 작성한다고 합니다.
근데 구글이의,
코딩 툴,
안티그래비티가 사실 제일 구리거든요?
제일 좋은 건 클로드 코드고,
그 다음에 코덱스고,
그 다음에 이제 구글의 코딩 툴이기 때문에,
제가 알기로는 구글이 클로드를,
구글 내에서는 클로드를 못 쓴다라고 알고 있는데,
구글이 클로드를 썼으면 아마 2%가 90%가 넘지 않을까?
감히 생각을 해 봅니다.
저도 요즘에 뭐 가끔 이제 클로드 코드를 뭘 만드는데,
저는 이제 코딩을 하지 않아요.
저는 코드를 보지도 않아.
이제는 아예.
제가 필요한 툴들을 만드는데 이제 볼 필요가 없어요.
그냥 결과가 마음대로 안 나오면,
그냥 계속 가스라이팅 하면 원하는 결과가 나오기 때문에,
저는 이제 코딩 화면 자체를 보지도 않습니다.
제가 하는 건 실행하는 거랑 엔터 치는 거 밖에 없습니다.
그런 상황이라서,
결국에는 이게 거의 한 95% 정도로 수렴하지 않을까라고 생각을 좀 해 보고요.
자 그리고 또 구글이 1분기에 얼마나 이제 퍼스트 파티,
구글 내에서 토큰을 사용하는가,
AI와 관련된 토큰을 사용하는가라는 걸 발표를 했는데,
아주 쉽게 말하면 구글이 토큰을 사용하는 그 속도,
쉽게 말해서 AI를 쓰는 속도가,
쓰는 속도가 더 빨라졌다.
지난 분기 QoQ로 43% 성장했는데,
이번 분기 QoQ로 60% 토큰 사용량이 더 증가했다.
AI와 관련된 걸 훨씬 더 구글 내부적으로 많이 쓰고 있다라는 얘기입니다.
그래서 AI는 계속 가고 있고,
AI는 계속 좋아지고 있어서,
모든 산업을 집어삼키고 있다.
그런 지표들이 뭐 여러 가지로 보이는 것 같고요.
저는 투자와 관련된 블로그 하고 있고,
투자와 관련된 인스타그램 하고 있으니까 궁금하신 분들은,
고정 댓글 설명란 참고 부탁드립니다.
감사합니다.